普通人怎么赚钱,给大家介绍一个赚钱无辜法,注意啊,这无辜法不是你第五步才能赚钱,是每一步都能赚钱
而且在非常的平均化,只是呢,就是越往后,你越秦松赚的钱就越多
这个是非常识草的,因为他我就这么看的,所以大家可以对你一下,你处在哪个階段
然后你使用相应的方法,不非话,我们就直接开始
首先,第1个,第1个可能让你听在可能会有点底处,但他其实是技术
我们多数人之所以不断钱,他的思维就是有一种说小聪明
比如说,我干活差不多就行了,这个其实是一个很大的阻礼
我差不多就行了,对吧,我都工了嘛,对吧,干怎么好干嘛
但是我们真正要干的,注意这个很重要,就是
我要想办法把这事干的好
干的更好
尽可能干到极致
我来说一下,为什么
这里没有两个很转的原因,第1个原因就是
当你想办法把他干好干的更好干到极致的时候,因为大部分都是差不多的情况
所以你很快就能冒头
很快能冒头,就是一想到做什么事情的时候,对,能力提升了嘛
一想到做什么事情的时候
老板
说过一点,首先想到的就是你
你看,那边这时候就一个账害了
首先想到我,我干的活更多
对不对,我不加心,我干的活更多
通常来说,这个时候是可以给你
甚至加心的,你拿我来说
我应该是在国际,很多都知道,就是给我们领导当同学
我当时干了很多,不是我分析的工作
对吧,比如说,打击外,附近击外了,基本击外的我来修
然后我去
不是我的工作,帮别打次,帮别人被标输,就是
做了很多,真的是网站,不该我干了我,我拿到网站的建设了
所以想到,大家首先会想到,我结果很快
一年吧
直接就是
成了一个新的部分
就专门符着这样的事情,那很难说,你是判他,他好几个,我们那个,他没那么好
那好,我要跟你讲的第二点事情
你可以跳草
你之所以不能跳草,是你的能力不够啊
对吧,如果你真的能力够的话,你是可以跳草啦
我们不是要跳草,但是我没要用,就是这个跳草这个,这个能力啊
我跟大家讲很多的
松职的地理钱,就赚钱的地理钱,这个多的地理钱,就是跳草
能力下,打一跳
转到百分之二,是百分之三的心情
对吧,你在
这个就不减了,但是我告诉你,这不是这个,这不是这个,这重要的是什么,这重要的是
你在你提升能力的同时,你在干净件事打,我你把一件事不断变好
变得更好的能力,这个很重要
好,这是第一件事,好像我在说《废话》,对不对,但是续续是可以帮助钱的
把你提升,其实,但
这不是这个,这就是第二,第二不非常非常的重要,但你,而且你能赚到钱
但不要只往他赚钱
什么意思
你要接死活了
现在我来往这么发达,你再往你可以接死活了,对吧
然后就找一个,你现在这个能力还可以看在什么呀,你去接死活
主意,你要是接不着死活,这个时候你就反思反行的,我
这个技能合适嘛
是因为这个技能本身这个市场就没有活
那怎么办
最后来办法,打算换技能呢
所以大家你要明白吗,你接死活的目的不是真的为了准钱
是为了验证你的能力,你能掉市场验证
一旦验证成功了,注意,这个时候你就不再,至少你有这个能力
不再是为你的老板打工
而是为市场打工
你自己就可以是一家公司
对吧,就这个时候你为发现
市场万一不好了,这个行业不好了,或者我被刺推了啊,我怎么能怎么样,对吧
我退休了
我仍然有通过能力来转接,这谁从市场验证能,如果这个不就马上推回地上,从新关系的
你能体会到国内点吗
好,我们和大家分享的第二个,第2个,就是这次活这个事,不注意它很重要
只能力的钱一,但不是的政策,第3条
我刚才说一步一步上,就身份开始,转换了啊,第3台外妈呢
在你接死活的国内中,刚才说了,再死活想着不要靠死的政策,它为什么去上,如果你能目的秀的政策,你会永远靠在这
你要干嘛呢,你要有目的的接一些活,这些活来了以后
你会找到活和活之间的重运
因为你靠这个机能吃大嘛,你可能有些都是重运过的
然后你就会发现有些东西是重运的,你就会把那边上复架
变成构架
变成构吧,变成流程,变成清单,变成各种各样的构件块
你拿我来说,我早期做第一个项目的时候,我记得是30,就是几十万吧
那小的几十万
很辛苦的,干了,干了大半年
所有第二个项目的时候,你会发现时间就越来越少了
我们到后面接几百万的项目的时候,其实一两位就干了
就很容易,为什么呢,因为都现场呢
多少现场呢,你只需要,稍微改动,你家数据又可以了
对不对,为什么因为大肯量的科技那么快可以做
所以,这个时候你要学会干一件事情
就是能力产品化
就是你开始突灵时间了
不再靠时间转秉了,你开始靠一些科服用的东西转秉了
所以这个时候,你要现象的一些事是什么呢
尽量不要用你更多的时间,用你更少的时间
最好
然后这个东西是可以打开两个复指的,就要你要做这件事情
好,第四件事
第四部,主义第四部和第三部并不排斥
你完全可以第三部做完那多的一次部,你也可以在多的三部的时候同时做的一次部,什么意思呢
就是你在做的过弄一定会多问题
然后你是怎么解决的
老婆就会反击的,我就怎么敢打啊
你开始要有自媒体的
喜欢张一号发视频,好,大家有心可以看过之前的文章
都是怎么敢的
就是
遇到的文体,什么问题,然后我怎么解决的,就会发现什么,算发什么,发发同一片文章
不是叫什么,好抱歉,就是这些就问题的,痛也就没翻
然后可以切你能力方法的,把方式去
这样的话,你就会发现你在不断的记得的资产,你除了那个内容之外,你还在记得资产
同时这个内容一对对别人有帮助,从而活得更多的用户
我后面很多用户都是因为看了我的文章找到我,说因为我能解决嘛,所以才能找到我
然后你就会发现这时候就会有
就会有用户,然后他们就会问你新的问题,这个就是可能是新的需求
然后你会发现还可能活得相应的用户,然后你的这个文章就会发现
可能不断帮你打磨产品,同时就可以活得用
第五
第五,其实你要购建系统了
什么系统啊,注意,这个时候你要很专注了
认真去做一件事的时候
把这个内容发布出来的获得用户,从市场中获得需求
不断的优务化我们的产品
不断优化我们的产品或者获得新的需求,购建新的产品
然后我再发布来获得更多用户,获得新的需求,不断的优化我们的产品
再发布来获得更多的用户
这是一个
这是一个完整的系统
这个时候你会发现你在靠系统转一下
有真正要完成升级
不是靠时间
所以这都不是靠技能,要不是靠能力,是靠系统转件的
所以各位,这是一个不走啊,首先第一个部分就是
这可能百件事干,做成极致提升的能力
第二件事情,你去做四国,做四国的目的不是为了赚钱
持卫的完成市场的严证,你不再是给公司打工
而是给市场打工
第三件事情,开始把手把能力装化成产品
因为产品能让你脱离
时间
更好的脱离时间,对吧
然后第四部,通过内容获得市场获得更多的用户
最后,通过系统完成复理